[Music]
good morning please welcome Jeff Lowe
good morning everyone and welcome to
next thank you I hope you all enjoyed
the keynotes as you heard we've been
making a tremendous amount of investment
here at Google to try to help
enterprises come to the cloud and
address your most critical most
important business challenges the
keynotes were packed as we all know
there's a lot of people still trickling
in unfortunately I'll have to you know
go through this a little bit quicker so
we'll get you back on schedule for
all-important lunchtime but again my
name is Jack and I have the privilege
and the honor to speak about a topic
that I'm personally very passionate
about namely how to help enterprises
bring together your on-prem environments
with your with Google cloud so as you
heard in the keynotes we believe that
there's this Nirvana ahead of building
cloud native applications and in fact at
Google over the past two decades we've
been building applications that support
billions of users in fact there are
eight applications ranging from search
and YouTube Gmail etc that actually have
taught us the value of building cloud
native applications now as we move to
public cloud we do believe that this is
ultimately the end state that everyone
should be striving for when you actually
build applications in the style not only
do you have the the ability to happen
portable but as you containerize
applications you take the benefits of
operational efficiencies you can
actually decouples from operating system
upgrades you can help your developers be
more efficient oftentimes you're
breaking them into micro services so
individual teams can work separately and
upgrade on their own cadence rather than
having to coordinate a large monolith
and in fact these basically are some of
the reasons that this model by
increasing your operational efficiency
and helping your agility
this is really what drives a lot of the
new directions in cloud and in software
development but as much as we want to go
up to that direction the reality is that
the majority of applications today are
down in what we would consider this
lower left quadrant they're sitting on
Prem their classic applications large
monoliths not easy to upgrade not easy
to kind of modify sometimes difficult to
maintain and so the question is what do
we actually do to address these
applications um ultimately we want to
take these these workloads and try to
find a way to get to the upper right
unfortunately that's just not so
straightforward you can have a whole
host of reasons why your applications
might be difficult to move to a new
development model or even a new
deployment model a wholesale migration
like this may seem extremely daunting
for most enterprises you know you might
say well you know I'm gonna I'm a risk
taker well I actually believe in the
future and so I'm gonna try to rip and
replace this is one term that oftentimes
people use to say you know essentially
I'm gonna start over I actually have an
important application I'm going to
reaaargh attacked it I'm going to
rewrite it so that I can get these
opportunities that come with a cloud
native application in the public cloud
but given the practical challenges and
complexities with such an approach this
is not the the path that most of the
time you'll take so let's look at a few
more incremental journeys to get to this
upper right nirvana so lift and shift
you know you've probably all heard about
this this approach where we're taking
existing applications and largely moving
them as is to the public cloud sometimes
this ends up being the most pragmatic
approach and the reasons might be
because you know the applications are
coming from a third party is v you may
not have source code them so you it's
not easy for you to rewrite them or RER
collect them and in a modern way or
perhaps you actually do have the source
code but these are applications that
were written by developers many many
years ago
most of whom may not even be at the
company anymore or they're a little bit
brittle and fragile so you're worried
about actually can you actually make
substantial changes because the
application is working just fine today
so in these cases moving to a public
cloud can still be bringing you benefits
the question is how do you actually make
that migration smooth and easy and later
on in this talk I'll describe a few ways
we've been doing that here at Google but
even if you just move the application as
is the migration to public cloud can
still bring you a lot of benefits for
example you might be running into a
situation where you have to upgrade your
physical infrastructure or turning down
your data centers and you have to make a
decision anyway to actually about where
you're gonna run your workloads at this
point if you move the applications to
GCP you can still get the benefits of
efficiency because now you don't have to
worry about managing the physical
infrastructure with capabilities like
our live migration and Google compute
engine we handle the upgrades of the
servers and the low-level software on
the machines while the applications
continue to run one great example of
this recently was the the processor
vulnerabilities spectra and meltdown
these were the largest security
vulnerabilities that have been
discovered in decades we were able on
Google cloud to be able to keep your
applications and workloads continually
running without actually having to
disrupt the applications and make those
patches to the underlying software
that's something that reduces an
operational burden from from your your
staff now beyond lifting shift you might
say well for some of my workloads I can
take it one incremental step further
what you might term as lifting modernize
or lift INRI platform and so what we
mean by this approach or this journey is
to take the step ups a workload that's
running on premises and then moving it
to a managed service so a great example
this might be a database where you can
now move it from an on-premise database
to cloud sequel or take your on-premise
Redis instance and move it to cloud
memory store
with this path with this journey you no
longer have to manage the service itself
that's handled by Google and allows you
to just move your application without
any code changes again a slightly lower
friction migration path that's available
to you to help you on your journey to
the cloud native alternate alternately
there's another direction which is to
improve first and then move and by this
what we mean is thinking about some of
the applications that you have today and
deciding to take that step and start to
containerize them so separate the
application from the operating system as
mentioned in the keynotes using
kubernetes to start to orchestrate these
containers and the deployment and
management of these applications most IT
organizations have already been adopting
kubernetes for at least some of the
applications and services and then once
you've learned of the technology learn
to deployment practices it becomes much
easier to take that next step to move to
the cloud now I'll mention yet another
journey here in addition to lift and
shift lifting and improve improve and
move is build and connect so this is a
little bit more about an architecture
style rather than a form of migration
and what I mean by architecture is some
of your complex applications and
services may have many many components
some of that are going to stay on
premises some of that will be running in
the cloud and in this kind of an
environment or architecture you'd be
looking at how to use things like Apogee
and developing API gateways to connect
that various components of your of your
system that span your multiple locations
I'll talk briefly about this later in
the talk
but at this point you know the thing
that comes through if you look at all
these journeys is that it's a complex
path to get to the cloud it can
certainly be very daunting you know most
of you live in a very diverse
heterogeneous world where you have
applications that are the shrink-wrapped
apps some of them you've developed
in-house
others might be saps and then on top of
that you have lots of different data
centers and environments some that you
own some that may be in a managed
service provider some that are in the
cloud and you may be using multiple
clouds at Google we recognize that
enterprises are complex and while we we
have a path that we think is the right
direction to take ultimately we want to
meet you where you are it's important to
let you run what you want where you want
to satisfy your business objectives so
how do you get started you know I think
an important thing to think about is
what are your goals you know are you
trying to move everything as quickly as
you can to the cloud or do you want to
take a more incremental approach as we
meet with customers oftentimes what
people look at is you know what are some
of the the easiest applications to move
first so pick some of your test dev
applications but also start planning an
architecture that allows you to move
your more complex workloads eventually
so breaking it up into waves and phases
part of the effort here is also around
understanding first discovering what
applications you have how can you assess
whether which these are good
applications to move do the planning and
then finally do the migration and then
once you've migrated them optimize them
so there's some multiple sessions here
at the conference where people go into
more detail about the programs that are
available through partners through PSO
to help you with this full migration
process but now that we've talked about
some approaches at a per application
level let's take a step back and think
about the holistic picture in the
keynote ORS describe the the notion of
hybrid and so ultimately what you need
to have is the infrastructure and
framework to think about how you manage
a diverse set of applications across a
diverse set of locations and this is
also a very critical part of your cloud
journey so what is hybrid you know I
think if you ask you know all the people
probably 500 people in the room we might
get you know 400 different answers of
exactly what hybrid means it has a lot
of different interpretations
but for the purposes of this talk I
think the footwear I want to focus on is
just the recognition that you do have
multiple locations and multiple
applications and services that need to
run in a location that suits you and
again put simply do what you want where
do you want and what we found is that
this approach is something that
resonates with customers this is a
survey of cloud users by I DC recently
and they found that 87% of cloud users
are hybrid they most more than half of
them have multiple kinds of cloud
deployments in their organization and a
large fraction of them 40% are cloud
first so a lot of these trends are very
likely to be accelerating practically
speaking hybrid is a reality it's a
state that's exists now it's going to
continue to increase and it's going to
be a state that's going to be here for
years to come
so how do you think about what you want
to do around hybrid one way is to break
it up into layers in an overall
architecture starting for the network
then looking at the application layer
and then the management layer so let's
look at each of these in turn so
networking obviously is the
underpinnings and in a sec I will go
into all some examples of how you might
build your hybrid network at the
application layer this is where there's
a lot of flexibility a lot of Technology
a lot of opportunity leveraging the
latest technologies like containers and
server lists as we heard in the keynotes
this morning the cloud services platform
and gke on-prem are examples of how you
actually build your applications and
services and spread across your hybrid
infrastructure now the and then on the
highest layer thinking about management
so let's go through a couple leaves
starting here so networking
so with with networking a Google Cloud
one important step in providing a hybrid
infrastructure is figuring out how to
connect your on-premise data center with
Google cloud so the virtual private
cloud or VPC is a way to actually create
an isolated network in GCP for your own
private access it allows you to make GCP
look like your own your own network but
when you connect it to your own data
center then it becomes simply an
extension of your on-premises footprint
but it's more than just connecting a
single data center to one GCP region the
single VPC can actually span multiple
regions across the globe without having
to go and out onto the public Internet
so why is that important well for
several reasons one from that single
on-premise data center you've now been
able to connect to all of the globe of
the Google regions you don't actually
have to set up a separate different
connection from your data center to each
of the regions that you want to operate
in secondly it gives you much lower and
more predictable Layton sees when you
actually have to connect across these
regions especially for those services
that you have that are large-scale
global services because you don't have
to go out into the public Internet and
then finally having a global VPC really
helps you in terms of manageability
because you can now have a single single
VPC policy that spans this network and
from a management standpoint that
simplifies your problem
so let's say you actually wanted to take
advantage of these technologies what are
what are some of the steps that you
would take so there are three different
options to connect your data center to
GCP the first is to use a more
traditional VPN like approach so with
cloud VPN you connect your your GCP in a
project to an on-premise VPN gateway and
then now you can encrypt data in transit
for some customers your requirements
might be more substantial and so this is
this you could choose to go down the
dedicated interconnect route in with
dedicated internet you bring your
network and you meet it at one of our
dedicated interconnect points of
presence we have more than 70 dedicated
pops across a worldwide and are
continuing to add to them which with
each of these interconnect points you
can get increments of 10 gigabytes
gigabits per second bandwidth but for
some customers perhaps you don't have
such us such demanding networking needs
and that's why we have a third option
which is called partner interconnect
this might be a case where you're not
really close to or your data centers
aren't sufficiently close to one of our
points of presence and so what you do is
you actually work with a partner the
port partner it has a peering location
with GCP and then you bring your network
to the partners you appear with the
partner this is a turnkey solution
integrated into the console and it
allows you to have a more flexible set
of networking options up to 10 gigabits
per second per VLAN all the way down to
50 megabits per second so that that
provides the the basic infrastructure
that you need for a hybrid architecture
moving up the stack to the application
layer you know there are many other
talks at the conference where people
will go into detail here we can spend
hours talking about what you wouldn't
want to build for hybrid applications I
think here I just want to highlight a
few of the basic principles namely
around portability abstraction and
automation
so the the ideas here are you want to
have a set of designs that allow
services and components to interoperate
in a meaningful way and so standardizing
on open source components open api's are
a key part of it and then once you do
this you want to be able to automate and
be able to manage at scale and then
finally moving up to the management
layer here you could choose to take a
variety of approaches depending on what
you may have standardized in your
environment and what you may decide you
want to actually change in your
environment basically it's kind of your
appetite for change so at the management
layer one of the most critical pieces of
your your stack is around monitoring so
you need to have a way to have ongoing
monitoring of the health of your
applications and services and
stackdriver provides a set of suite of
tools that give you operational
awareness there's a set of tools for
logging and monitoring the services that
are running into running inside of say
virtual machines or running in terms of
other you know containers and it doesn't
matter where they're running they could
be on GCP they can be running on premise
they could running elsewhere and this is
one way to kind of unify your your
management of your of your workloads a
second path is kubernetes as was
announced this morning with gke on prem
we now have the ability to have a single
control experience that manages across
the cloud and on-premises so no matter
where you run them on your internal
datacenters or in the cloud you can have
a consistent experience and the third
one is maybe aimed at some of you who
might have VMware environment so you
might be might have lots of tools and
practices built up around your VMware
infrastructure we've been partnering
with VMware to build a plug-in to fit in
to that set of tools so we recently last
week announced that we've been that
we've been working together on a plugin
for V realized automation and we
realized Orchestrator so for those of
you who aren't familiar
with this environment essentially what
what some customers have done is created
a a portal or a sort of their own
private cloud and they create blueprints
this is one of the more common use cases
for these tools where you've identified
if some end-user wants to actually
create an application you click on a
blueprint it automatically deploys
resources now for those people who are
using VR o or VRA the natural extension
is being able to back those resources
with resources in GCP and so the this
this plugin allows you to get some of
the benefits of cloud while continuing
to use your existing management
infrastructure so now you can use a
blueprint the blueprint actually creates
virtual machines in Google compute
engine and now those workloads can take
advantage of things like you know on
basically lower cost compute because you
have the various forms of discounts like
sustain use or a custom committee use
discounts the custom machine types and
this environment is now running and
using resources in the cloud even though
you're using your existing on-premises
management infrastructure so this plugin
is an EAP right now if you're interested
in taking a look there's a sign-up for
for you to take part look at folks a
second take a picture
all right so we've talked a little bit
about various journeys that you would
take for applications to get to the
cloud
we've talked a little bit about a hybrid
architecture that you might want to
think about when you're coming in the
cloud but you still have to figure out
how you can move those actual workloads
and that data as quickly as possible so
if you're going down this path you know
what are some of the biggest challenges
you're gonna run into a recent survey
showed that most migration projects
unfortunately aren't super successful
about 94% of them run into delays
they're over budget we've often heard
even of cases where people have moved
workloads to the cloud only to move them
back because of something they didn't
realize something they didn't plan for
properly why is this hard well a lot of
organizations have not just hundreds but
maybe thousands of workloads and
applications that they need to move so
how do you handle the scale how do you
figure out which applications to move
what the dependencies are it's pretty
daunting not to mention the fact that
organizationally you will have different
owners of these applications and you may
need to get their approval in the
migration process
another area of complexity is you can
they come from different sources many of
them could be running in virtual
machines on vmware they could be running
on physical some of them could be in
another cloud and you want to move them
to GCP of course we have also complexity
your most mission critical workloads say
it's an S ap or an Oracle database these
are applications that are business
critical you do want to take advantage
of moving them to the cloud but the
problem is it's you can't take any
business risk and you don't even want to
take any downtime or at least keep that
downtime to an absolute minimum so that
lasts that those concerns lead into this
question of risk how can you actually
prepare yourself and test and is there a
way that you can make sure that it's
highly likely that workloads succeed
when you move them but in the worst case
if things don't go well you can roll
back fortunately we came across a
partner that we've been working with for
a while called Bella strata and we
recently announced
in acquisition about a month ago that
closed they were already a partner
helping with migrations to Google cloud
but we found that it's a very
complimentary team technology and
product and really what they are
enabling us to do is provide an
enterprise-grade
purpose-built solution for helping
accelerate the migrations of workloads
to GCP not only can they move from
on-premises to Google cloud but you can
also move from AWS to GCP so this
technology and this product is is a real
enabler to reducing the friction
involved in these complex migrations one
of the key capabilities is that it
allows you to move your workloads very
quickly oftentimes with less than ten
minutes of downtime and that's pretty
amazing like if you think about how you
want to actually reduce the the impact
and reuse the friction of a migration if
you can reduce that downtime this is a
critical advantage
so the typical migration what will
happen is you'll have a bunch of data
the disks associated with your VMs and
you need to copy that up to the cloud
before you can actually migrate and if
it's a large VM let's say a terabyte
virtual disk that's going to take some
time that could take hours now you
multiply that by hundreds of workloads
or thousands and you can see how long
this process can take the key insight
from the develop strategy muahh x' to
look at how you decouple compute from
storage and so the idea is that actually
you can stream cloud in the Karim the
the storage so essentially what happens
is you take a short downtime period at
the beginning and you start bringing
over the most critical pieces of the
storage and there's a lot of
intelligence and when optimization in
the in this technology that allows you
to start that process and that's once
you've moved those critical pieces you
can start running your workload in the
cloud while the rest of the data gets
migrated in the background you know they
say a picture is worth a thousand words
so let's let's take a look at this graph
what it shows here is this is from a
customer example on
on this is showing time on the x-axis
and why is both the number of VMs enter
running let's our that have been moved
to the cloud as well as in green the
amount of data that's been migrated so
this customer chose to make two weeks
prints to actually do the migration and
you can see that there's a step function
in the first week what they would do if
just kind of blow it into one of these
sprints they did some discovery and
planning so picking up say 75 VMs that
they actually wanted to migrate so
figure out which ones they are kind of
plan internally how they would move them
actual Schedule II the Mike of the
migration and then the second week do
the actual migration now what you can
see in this blown-up zoom is that most
of the VMS were moved and running in the
cloud in hours meanwhile the data is
streaming in the background and in fact
it took about three days for all the
data to get there but in this time the
customer was able to actually start
running these applications again and not
impact their business and when you think
about you know the amount of time you
have to do migrations this means you can
easily do a migration of a large number
of workloads over a weekend and that and
be able to take rather than trying to
look at many many days of moving a lot
of data so you know why is this
important well one you know minimizing
the downtime and then taking advantage
of other capabilities in the tool set to
be able to validate and increase the
confidence that your workloads are
successful you know as I mentioned
earlier often times less than 10 minutes
in you're up and running you save a lot
of manpower you accelerate the the
process of migration and this actually
greatly increases the likelihood that a
migration project will be successful
because you can stay on your budget but
earlier I mentioned one of the
challenges was around Rick's risk and
complexity what this technology also
allows you to do is roll back
unfortunately there's a conflicting
deep-dive session right now going on
about the vel estrada technology and so
hopefully you can see that a video or
looks at some of the collateral online
but there's also the
you need to roll back because while
we're streaming the data to the cloud
they're still data for that virtual
machine running on-premises and if you
find for some reason that maybe you
forgot to move a workload and that that
it depends on or you have some other
challenge you'll always have the ability
to move back and that safety net that
insurance policy is you know very
valuable when it comes to actually doing
these large-scale migrations and
ultimately now by getting these
migrations to happen you can get to ramp
up your Cloud usage much more quickly
now in addition to migrating your
virtual machines you may actually also
have a lot of data that needs to be
migrated the data transfer appliance is
one solution that's available to help
take if you have say hundreds of
terabytes of data that you need move the
cloud in addition to your virtual
machines you just you know can't afford
to actually move all that data this is
not necessarily so much for the virtual
machines in the Val Estrada case but it
could be because you have some some data
warehouse or other large amounts of data
that you need to be able to use while
you're in the cloud so the transfer
appliance comes in to you in a form fap
to you and for you form factors with
hundred terabyte and 480 terabyte
versions the larger one can handle up to
roughly about a petabyte of data
compressed basically it's as simple as
going to the console requesting a
transfer appliance you get it you rack
it you fill it up with data and then
ship it back to us basically this is a
solution where you can actually have it
sit in the data center for a while and
then bring it back to Google Cloud so
now that I've talked a little bit about
some of the migration challenges and and
some of the solutions that are available
I wanted to bring one of our customers
from Cardinal Health John Lott Shaw
who's the vice president of cloud
services at Cardinal and have them talk
a little bit about the company and and
some of the work they've been doing with
Google John thank you for having me
so so John can you first tell the
audience and tell us a little bit about
Cardinal health which you guys do we do
a lot of things but in summary we try to
make health care more efficient and cost
effective we're a fortune 15 company
with about 130 billion dollars in
revenue about 700 sites and a lot of
applications not to be too specific yeah
so when one other point if if any of you
have had the misfortune to be in a
hospital or need to get a prescription
for some sort of illness you've probably
used our services just going to a CVS or
some sort of hospital one of the things
when I was visiting you guys recently
hearing the stories about like the kind
of odd demand nature of the business
you're in
like someone ordering something today
for a patient that has a procedure
tomorrow and you know critical services
that you have to deliver to make sure
that happen it's hard to plan
emergencies yeah
so can you talk a little bit about what
prompted Cardinals migration to the
cloud yeah it's in a nutshell its speed
and efficiency so we our businesses is
hard to predict you wouldn't think that
from if you look at health care but it's
actually a large component of businesses
pharmaceutical distributions so where
drugs need to be where generics might
launch and so a lot of that requires us
to turn on a dime and with traditional
infrastructure it's just hard to do
whereas conversely with GCP I can spin
up spin down all at a moment's notice
and then although we have a hundred and
thirty billion dollars in revenue we
actually run on grocery store margins so
every penny counts so we've found that
running in the cloud if you do it the
right way can be considerably more cost
effective than doing it ourselves
yep so with that in mind I mean can you
talk about some of the best practices or
perhaps lessons learned that you guys
have experienced yeah kind of go back a
little bit in your presentation if you
haven't heard of El Estrada go check it
out it's the real deal we were one of
their first customers
makes a tremendous difference if you're
doing any kind of lift and shift or lift
and lately optimized migrations there's
a lot of that we're doing and it really
works as advertised it sounded a lot
like magic to me when they first pitched
it and it is proven to be a great
partner and it works so on that you know
we've we're about a third of the way
through and we've learned a lot of
things I'd say there's there's one thing
I would say the technology is not the
hardest part of this so it while it is
challenging in some aspects don't worry
about that so much what I would say is
get your house in order while you're
contemplating moving move some non proud
were cloades
but before you move production make sure
that your CMDB is accurate and
up-to-date
we had a very complete CMDB we could go
through and say all the fields were
filled out but when we wanted to gain
intelligence about our systems like what
systems were part of a business process
what applications need to talk to what
applications on what ports it wasn't
reliable because we never had to use it
like that so spend some time getting
that stuff in order and and be sure you
can answer the right questions about
what needs to talk to what I would say
be friends with your finance people this
change is going to have a ripple effect
of substantial changes through the
finance team they need to be prepared
for you know direct chargebacks you
don't have to do direct chargebacks we
chose to it drives the right behavior
but it is a massive adjustment for them
lastly partner up maybe by your seaso
bottle of their favorite beverage
repeatedly security folks by the nature
extremely cautious google has an
enormous emphasis on security but it's
not only their responsibility it's a
joint responsibility and and we've spent
a lot of time on bringing the bringing
the the security folks along getting our
CCO on board getting an endorsement so
that's kind of in a nutshell if I had it
to do over again I
would spend more time up front on those
things and less time worrying about the
technology great so can you also talk a
little bit about your experience with
Google cloud specifically you know what
has kind of served out with with that
partnership a couple things there one
they've been a great partner
so they've their product teams have been
very curious we've gotten access to that
so for those that are kind of just
dipping the toe in the water if you've
had experience with on-premise companies
like no database company that begins
with an O or something like that and you
say hey it'd be great to have this
feature in your next release maybe in a
year two years I might come out we've
had the experience of working with our
product teams to say hey on your API
gateway we would like this and they're
like okay cool and like literally six
weeks later we have that feature so
they've been extremely responsive
extremely curious on what it takes for
us to move the cloud and it's not an
unselfish investment I mean we're a lot
like every other fortune 500 we have the
widest variety of systems you can
imagine and if Google invests in making
us successful then that just paves the
way for everyone else I found their
infrastructure their network to be fast
and reliable more so than than other
cloud providers we've looked at live
migrations a big feature for us we did
some things internally that I call kind
of unnatural acts but it was to save on
licensing fees for like some WebSphere
products where we would create a VM that
had two CPUs but 48 gig of ram and we
did that because you know we wanted to
say about licensing so in some cases
we're gonna unwind that and we're gonna
do it the right way in the cloud some
cases we can't and so that their custom
machine size gives us that flexibility
to do that instead of the kind of
t-shirt sizing that other cloud
providers have great well thank you so
much John like you
[Applause]
it's great to have the opportunity of
you know fantastic customers like John
and his team and looking forward to you
know collaborating further on their
their continued journey into the cloud
so before I wrap up here I wanted to
just highlight a number of sessions
there's actually probably many other
ones that are related to the topics that
we've talked about where you can get a
little bit deeper there are some
customers who have all said we can talk
about their their experiences moving to
GCP or if you want to look at other
different technologies and products that
have done migrations to cloud here's a
few sessions and as I mentioned earlier
unfortunately that one one two sessions
going on right now so I just want to
leave you all with a few important
takeaways I think you know what I would
try to do is paint the journeys that
that you might want to take and it's
really important to recognize that this
modernization of IT is important there's
a great opportunity here to improve
efficiencies and help your business be
you know help you accelerate your
business rather than having IT
infrastructure just be a lot of about
cost but ultimately Google's here to
meet you where you are we have a vision
for where we want it to take everyone
but along the way everyone might have a
slightly different journey second is
hybrid is just the reality it is going
to require rethinking a little bit about
your architecture from a network to a
management to an application standpoint
but it's important to have a vision for
where you want to go because this is a
reality that's here for many many years
ahead and then finally the journey is is
long it's complex but we're here to
support you whether it's through PSO
through the many partners we have here
at the conference from the engineering
teams from the customer teams we're here
to help you make be successful there's a
lot of resources and tools and guides
and so please you know reach out if you
need help with your migration and thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]